In this video, we'll
solve our sports
scheduling problem
in LibreOffice.
We can use the solver to solve
integer optimization problems
using the same process as for
linear optimization problems.
The only difference
is that we need
to add extra constraints
to define variables
as integer or binary.
Let's go ahead and solve our
small tournament scheduling
problem.
In LibreOffice, or in
the spreadsheet software
you're using, go ahead
and open the spreadsheet
SportsScheduling.ods.
At the top of the
spreadsheet, I've
created a spot for our
decision variables.
We have a decision
variable for each week,
weeks one through four,
and for each team pair:
A and B, A and C, A and
D, B and C, B and D,
and C and D. This gives
us a total of 24 decision
variables highlighted in yellow.
Below the decision
variables, there's
a spot for our objective,
highlighted in blue.
Let's go ahead and
construct our objective.
Start by typing an
equals sign, and then we
want it to be equal to 1 times
the decision variable for A
and B in week 1, plus 2 times
and B in week 2, plus 4 times
the decision variable for A
and B in week 3, plus
8 times the decision
variable for A and B in week 4.
Now we want to repeat
this for teams C and D.
So now we have 1 times the
decision variable for C and D
in week 1, plus 2 times the
in week 2, plus 4 times the
decision variable for C and D
in week 3, plus 8 times the
in week 4.
Go ahead and hit Enter.
Our objective has
value 0 for now
because we haven't filled in
our decision variables yet.
Now, let's construct
our constraints.
The first constraint is teams
A and B should play twice.
So our left hand side should
be equal to the sum-- we'll
use the sum function
here, which just adds up
everything inside
the parentheses.
So type =sum, and
then in parentheses,
select the four A and
B decision variables.
The sign should be equals
and the right hand side
should be 2.
Now let's just repeat
this for teams C and D.
So the left hand side is the
sum of the C and D decision
variables, the sign is equals,
and the right hand side is 2.
Now we want to add the
constraint that teams A
and C should play once, so this
left hand side is very similar.
It should be the sum of the
A and C decision variables,
the sign should be equals,
and the right hand side here
should be 1.
Now let's repeat this
for teams A and D.
The left hand side is the sum of
the A and D decision variables,
the sign is equals, and
the right hand side is 1.
We'll repeat it again
for teams B and C.
So the left hand side is the
sum of the B and C decision
variables, the sign is equals,
and the right hand side is 1.
The last of this
type of constraint
is that teams B and
D should play once,
so the left hand side is the
sum of the B and D decision
variables, the sign is equals,
and the right hand side is 1.
Now we want to add
the constraints
that each team should only
play once in each week.
So the first is that team A
should play once in week one.
So the left hand side should be
the sum of all of the decision
variables where A
plays in week one.
So this should be equal to
A playing B in week one,
plus A playing C in week one,
plus A playing D in week one.
The sign is equals, and the
right hand side is again 1.
Now let's repeat
this for week two.
So the left hand side is equal
to A playing B in week two,
plus A playing C in week two,
plus A playing D in week two.
The sign is equals and
the right hand side is 1.
Now let's repeat this
for weeks three and four.
So for week three,
the left hand side
is just equal to the variables
of A playing with week three:
A and B, A and C, A and
D. The sign is equals
and the right hand side is 1.
For week four,
the left hand side
is just the A variables in
week four, A and B, A and C,
and A and D. The
sign should be equals
and the right hand side is 1.
I went ahead and filled in the
rest of the constraints for you
since they're just repeating
the same thing for team B,
team C, and team D.
Now we're ready to
solve our problem.
So let's go to the "Tools"
menu and select "Solver".
In the Solver window, let's
first pick our target cell.
So with the cursor in
the "Target cell" box,
go ahead and select
the objective cell,
or the blue cell.
Make sure that
"Maximum" is selected,
since we're trying to
maximize preferences.
Then, with the cursor in
the "By changing cells" box,
go ahead and select all
24 decision variables.
Now, let's add in
our constraints.
Since all of our constraints
have an equals sign,
we can add them all in together.
So in the first
Cell Reference box,
go ahead and select all
of the left hand sides.
In the Operator
box, select equals.
Then, in the Value box, select
all of the right hand sides.
Since this is an integer
optimization problem,
there's one more thing we need
to do in the constraint area.
In the Cell Reference
box, go ahead
and select all of the
decision variables.
Then, in the operator pull
down menu, select Binary.
This will make all of our
decision variables binary.
We don't need to put
anything in the Value column.
The last thing we need
to do is in Options,
make sure that we're using the
linear solver, and click OK.
Now, go ahead and hit Solve.
The solving results says:
solving successfully
finished, result 24.
Go ahead and pick Keep
Result, and now let's
look at our solution.
We can see that teams A
and B and teams C and D
both play during weeks 3 and 4.
This makes sense, since we're
trying to maximize preferences,
and the preference for
teams in the same division
is to play later on.
In the next video, we'll see the
different types of constraints
that we can add to an
integer optimization model.